[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en France 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares
dos hombres el comandante en meti el
general alburham han sumido a Sudán en
el caos y la incertidumbre por su
rivalidad la situación de tensión entre
estos dos generales a escalado en
enfrentamientos en los últimos días lo
que ha dejado decenas de muertos y
centenares de heridos en el país
en working afa son los militares en el
poder decretaron una movilización
general de toda la población en nombre
de la lucha contra el yihadismo esta
medida otorga amplios poderes a las
autoridades que ahora podrán movilizar a
personas o bienes y en el contexto de
inseguridad en la región del zagel una
de las causas y consecuencias más
preocupantes es la estigmatización de la
etnia fulani a menudo los miembros de
esta etnia están erróneamente
relacionados con los yihadistas
analizamos este tema con José Naranjo
periodista del diario El País y
especialista en esta región
desde hace semanas los uraneses venían
escuchando rumores de una inminente
guerra entre dos bandos esa ola de
pánico se hizo realidad el ejército y
los paramilitares fuerza de apoyo rápido
Iniciar una escalada Armada acusándose
mutuamente de haber atacado sus
respectivas unidades lo que ha asumido
al país en el caos y el miedo y agravado
su ya inestable situación la rivalidad
entre el jefe de los paramilitares El
general
y el General
jefe del ejército y dirigente de facto
de Sudán son el origen de esta situación
estos dos hombres que juntos expulsaron
a los civiles del poder en el golpe de
estado de octubre de 2021 terminaron
enfrentados pero son los civiles quienes
están pagando el precio más alto según
el sindicato oficial de médicos
decenas de personas han muerto y
centenares han resultado heridas para
entender lo que está ocurriendo en este
país del noreste de África conversamos
con Alexis y lorent investigador
especialista en la región del cuerno de
África nos explicó Cómo se ha llegado a
esta situación en Sudán después de que
si firmó en diciembre de 2022 un acuerdo
para entregar el poder a los civiles
ahora con el último acuerdo
último acuerdo que se finalizó se firmó
en diciembre en 2022
parecía que después de que el militar
habían vuelto en el poder
en el año anterior
estaban otra vez parecen que
interesados en firmar con las partes
Civiles para que para que civiles
tomarían El poder del nuevo después de
un periodo de transición de dos años
a partir de diciembre a partir de la
firma y
también se acordó que las fuerzas
paramilitares de geometti se sometería
o se someterían a una integración a las
fuerzas armadas militares
pero aquí tenemos la situación ahora que
es que es lo que se ha agudizado
bastante porque parece que los que los
dirigentes militares y paramilitar no
están dispuestos en ceder el poder en
una forma tan rápida y claro estos
intereses de intentar sobreponerse
políticamente y económicamente
y continuar
este status quo en el país
sigue siendo importante
el especialista nos comentó también si
existe riesgo de una guerra civil
Entonces tenemos varios
varios ejes de que tienen poder militar
y luego tenemos civiles en el centro de
todo esto
civiles que están realmente teniendo
bastantes dificultades
en la situación actual en jartum pero en
otras partes del país también en varias
ciudades
por justamente por esta lucha entre
militares y paramilitares están como
quedando
entre entre estas estas fuerzas
Entonces
esta situación tiene
potencial de de
llegar a una guerra civil
bastante
diría que la posibilidad de llegar a eso
es bastante importante ahora mismo
cambiamos de tema y continuamos en
burkina faso donde el presidente de la
transición Ibrahim traoré ha dado un
nuevo paso en su guerra contra los
grupos yihadistas el jefe de la junta
militar ha decretado una movilización
general según las actas del Consejo de
ministros la adopción de esta medida
confiere a la junta en el poder unas
prerrogativas que le permitirían
movilizar personas bienes y servicios
restringir la libertad de circulación de
expresión y de reunión controlar los
recursos energéticos y los productos
industriales
como sus vecinos de la región del Zag el
burkina faso sufre desde 2015 una
espiral de violencia yihadista según las
ongs en los últimos 7 años la guerra ha
dejado más de 10.000 muertos y unos 2
millones de desplazados una de las
causas y también de las consecuencias de
esta violencia es la guerra entre
comunidades producto de ello existe
ahora en la región la creencia
generalizada de que los miembros de la
etnia fulani constituyen el grueso de
las tropas yadistas así desde 2015 los
fulanie se han convertido en las
principales Víctimas de los abusos
cometidos por las fuerzas armadas bajo
la justificación de la lucha
antiterrorista antes de seguir veamos
Quiénes son los fulani los fulani
también conocidos Como
representan unos 40 millones de personas
están presentes en los países del sahel
y África occidental la gran mayoría son
pastores casi todos son musulmanes e
históricamente desempeñaron un papel
importante en la entrada del islam en
África occidental para hablar de la
situación cada vez más precaria de los
fulanie recibimos a José Naranjo
periodista en el sahel para el diario
español el país José Hola Gracias por
estar con nosotros
Cómo surgieron estas tensiones entre
comunidades en el
bueno la comunidad pelo fulani que son
estamos hablando de más de 40 millones
de personas repartidas en un montón de
países sobre todo de África occidental
se dedicó tradicionalmente al pastoreo
eran nómadas o seminómadas que iban con
sus vacas pues recorriendo por distintas
zonas y cuando
durante el siglo 18 19 protagonizaron
además fueron los que de alguna manera
trajeron el islam a la región es un
pueblo que tenía un cierto prestigio
como sabios del islam etcétera y cuando
llega la colonización europea ellos
quedan un tanto excluido un tanto al
margen porque el proyecto colonizador
tanto el francés como el inglés o el de
otras antiguas metrópolis se apoya sobre
todo en comunidades sedentarias y
agricultores por lo tanto los pastores
no más diseminómadas de alguna manera
quedan un tanto excluidos de esta nueva
sociedad surge desde la colonización y y
se van quedando atrás en Campos como
como el de la educación el empleo
etcétera y ellos se aferran a sus
tradiciones a su cultura a su manera de
entender la religión y no se integran de
una manera tan fluida como como otras
comunidades en los nuevos países que
nacen a raíz de las independencias en
los años 60 todo esto hace que además
viven en una zona muy complicada donde
el cambio climático avanza un ritmo
tremendo estamos viendo sequías lluvias
cada vez más irregulares y esto ha sido
también un acelerador de las tensiones
por recursos cada vez más escasos como
la tierra y el agua entre estos pastores
nómadas y seminómadas digamos que se
sienten agraviados por un estado que no
les ha cuidado lo que ellos consideran
que tenía que haber sido y otras
comunidades que Que bueno que que están
de alguna manera Por así decirlo muy
entre comillas invadiendo esas tierras
de pastoreo tradicionales
y en el Sí suele acusar a los fulanie de
robustecer las filas de las
organizaciones yihadistas existen cifras
o estadísticas sólidas que lo demuestren
no De hecho
no existe una estadística fiable del
perfil étnico de los grupos yihadistas
sí que se sabe que hay de todas las
etnias O sea no son solo los pelos los
fulanes pero sí que es verdad que el
hecho de que la esta insurgencia
yihadista en níger se produce sobre todo
allí donde Hay comunidades Perlas no hay
comunidades fulanie eso ya contribuye al
hecho de que de que miembros de esta
comunidad se sienten tentados por
ingresar la las filas de los grupos
yihadistas había hay un reciente estudio
de Naciones Unidas en el que apunta a
las causas del reclutamiento
o del alistamiento de jóvenes en los
grupos yihadistas y sobre todo está la
pobreza y la falta de de la
imposibilidad de tener unas expectativas
no Entonces en un lugar muy pobre donde
hay una comunidad que se siente
y que
es digamos una tentación para para
muchos jóvenes unirse a grupos que
además vienen con esta pistola que dicen
que lo van a defender no frente a
aquellos que los han estado un poco
machacando no en las últimas décadas
pero no sabemos si realmente
se intuye que hay una mayoría de fulani
Y esto es así yo creo que es innegable
que hay muchos miembros de la comunidad
o fulani que integran los grupos
yihadistas pero también los hay de otra
etnia y además es una obviedad pero no
todos los pelis y los fulani son
yihadistas no yo creo que ahí es de
donde procede también el error de la
amalgama de la estigmatización de toda
una etnia cuando son unos cuantos muy
pocos no los que se unen a los grupos
y mi última pregunta se refiere a la
medida que acaba de tomar el gobierno de
burkina faso que quiere una movilización
general de la población contra el
yihadismo las comunidades fulani podrían
verse aún más afectadas por esta medida
sin duda
porque cuando son los ejércitos o
digamos las fuerzas regulares las que
intervienen en un en un determinado
incidente o en una determinada operación
se les pueden exigir responsabilidades
pero cuando estamos hablando de grupos
civiles
cuyo marco jurídico no está del todo
definido no está del todo claro la la
impunidad ante matanzas por ejemplo
podría ser peor Y además estamos
hablando de gente que posiblemente no
tiene una formación básica o mínima en
derechos humanos o en el derecho de
dentro de Las Guerras también hay un
unos convenios y unos acuerdos
establecidos el respeto de la vida de
los prisioneros etcétera Pero claro aquí
estamos hablando de grupos paramilitares
o de civiles a los que se entrega un
arma pero que no reciben la adecuada
formación en materia de Derechos Humanos
los las comunidades y las comunidades lo
han han advertido los grupos de derechos
humanos tienen mucho que temer ante un
conflicto generalizado como el que hacia
el que se va en burkina faso con una
importante participación de la población
civil
José Naranjo gracias por su aporte
así termina esta edición de África siete
días Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional continúa en
France 24